hey what's up guys my name is a channel
and welcome to a video discussing the
future of Sparky so as you can see I'm
dressed pretty formally because this is
a very serious video so we got serious
Cherno over here and basically this
video and I mean I'm here in the flesh
as well doing a vlog kind of thing
because this is legit so basically this
video is going to be discussing the
future of the Sparky engine as you might
as you may have noticed I haven't really
put out put out a video I don't know
strain for Spock you know while that's
just because I've been taking a break
from it don't worry nothing's getting
cancelled you guys always get really
really dramatic when I start making
videos that's and it's gonna continue
obviously I wouldn't just abandon such a
beautiful project
I just wanted to switch up to game
programming because people were begging
me to do game programming and of course
once I started game programming people
were begging me to bring back Sparky
anyway the point is that's all of this
videos gonna be about that this video is
going to be about bringing well actually
everything that we're going to do with
Sparky in the future almost things of
course so in the immediate future the
first thing I want to do so Sparky
season 1 is kind of over right that was
where we basically did everything
necessary to get the engine of its fade
2d engine off its fate to the point
where we could even basically build it
for the web using Emscripten right so
the big the grown inside WebGL so right
now suppose Windows and when WebGL
basically has two platforms now I'm
actually for season two which will start
probably within the next two weeks or
definitely within the next two weeks I
should say I'm actually probably going
to change up the format of Sparky so
right now the way that it works is I
stream live everything that I do and I
am I end up uploading to our videos
which is well one to two hour videos
which is essentially one episode of
Sparky and the reason they're so long is
primarily cuz of course I don't really
know what I'm doing right the making a
game engine is and all I'm not see I'm
not making a tutorial on how to make a
game engine I'm actually making a game
engine so of course there's a bunch of
stuff that I'm not sure about there's a
bunch of mistakes I'm making it's not
like I've written a book or I've written
an engine and then I'm like alright
let's teach people how to do this I'm
actually making this in front of you
guys because of that of course it's
going to take a while there are going to
be things I don't know there are going
to be things I need to redo
and there are gonna be moments where I
just stare at the screen for an hour
because I don't know why this is why
something's not working or I don't know
how to do something and I need to work
it out right these things take time
that's normal so what's happening
unfortunately because of that as a
result as a consequence is that this
stuff is going on YouTube and people are
like people are getting to our videos to
their sub boxes and they're being like
well I shouldn't say to our because most
of them around one hour should say 1
hour 1 hour videos to their sub boxes
most people like man like I'd really
like to watch that but I'm like 10
episodes behind and they're all an hour
long and I don't have time and as a
consequence basically the series isn't
doing extremely well and most of you
guys aren't really watching that and I
think it breaks down into two reasons
one the episodes are long and not really
like it requires a lot of time to
actually keep up with the series and to
it since they bus Plus and most of you
are used to Java and it's just boggling
your mind so those are two issues so I'm
going to try and resolve both of those
issues somehow so the first thing is the
format change what I want to do is this
okay and this is probably what I'm going
to do I would love your feedback in the
comments below but regard I'm very I'm
leaning towards it and it's probably
gonna happen I'm going to change the way
I do this first of all I will still be
streaming all the did most of the most
of the development life there are times
where I'm at work for example on my
lunch break and I really want to work on
this thing and of course I can't or I
have 15 minutes and I'd love to just
write a bit of code but I can't because
of course I need to stream it and
because of that the development of the
engine really really really suffers what
if I'm at you know what if I'm not home
what if I'm at my parents place and I've
got my laptop I'd love to just write
some code but I've you know I'm gonna
stream in like it it becomes very very
very very bad for the actual engine's
development because it just slows it
down dramatically okay so the first
thing I want to do is probably not
stream or do all of the development if
I'm home
and I've got at least half an hour I'll
put up the live stream there's no reason
for me not to do that it's just I press
a button and there we go I'm life and I
love doing that so I will be doing that
as much as possible but it won't be all
of the engine the other thing is but of
course all the card will be
if you really want you can look at the
diffs and figure out what I've done and
and but there's more
so wait before you start complaining all
the livestreams that do happen I'm aware
the twitch deletes them after two weeks
so I do want to put them up however I do
not want to put them up on my main
channel because people will get two hour
long videos or streams or whatever and
it's just it really makes this channel
messy and it lowers the quality of the
channel because there are some videos
your watch will be terrible some
sometimes will be me staring at a screen
of half now I don't want that I have
like a standard that I want to meet in
terms of quality for this channel so I
don't want to do that I do want to put
them up somewhere because twitch will
delete them so I I'm basically what I'm
going to do is I want to make a new
channel some called something on the
lines of Cherno archive or something and
I'm going to basically just click the
export to YouTube button on Twitch it's
just gonna put the unedited stream at
whatever load bitrate it was streamed at
to that channel so that if you really
really want to you can actually you can
actually watch the entire stream okay so
you can do that don't want to be I'm
aware that obviously watching a stream
it in Australian Eastern Standard Time
like evenings usually is it very very
bad for people in Europe and America so
I'm thinking of you as well I'm going to
just put that onto that Channel archive
channel and you guys can watch away if
you really really for the full of you
hardcore people so that you can actually
watch the entire stream okay and that's
fine I'm definitely gonna do that but
the main channel what what the main
channel will receive is basically dev
locks or summary videos so maybe once a
week depending on how often I'm
developing this thing once a week once
every two weeks I'll put up a video
probably once a week
just detailing all the changes I've made
in the past week and maybe even looking
at diff and looking at and by diffs I
mean like the the differences that I've
made to file so if you can basically see
them highlighted and I'll explain them
roughly I'll show you the new features
I'll talk about what I've done and what
I want to do with this and the problems
and you know like a summary a dev vlog
basically so that will be put up on the
main channel they'll be between 5 to 10
minutes and from there you guys will be
able to request essentially let's just
say I did something like something weird
that you guys didn't
understand or like something that you
would love a video on for example I did
something weird with my renderer where I
I don't know
I'm I don't know I copied the memory
somewhere and then did something crazy
I'm making stuff up I did something
weird and you don't know how that what
that taught you we'd love to learn more
about that technique in that case I'm
going to read the comments from those
dev logs and once per week or whatever
I'll choose the most uploaded comment on
something and I'll make an in-depth
video about that but here's the trick
the in-depth video is going to be
basically completely separate from
Sparky so the in-depth video will
basically be universal so I'll just talk
about that technique in general I might
use some of the Sparky code but so that
anyone who comes the channel doesn't
have to watch the entire series to just
watch that video and learn that one
thing because I've always wanted to do
that because of course when we've got
series like game programming with over
100 videos if people really want to do
something they need to watch 100 videos
to get it's terrible I hate it so I'm
going to do that so that anyone could
just pick up the video and watch it and
regardless of where they are in the
series and those will be in the video so
there we go
that's the main plan with the format
changes I hope you guys like that I hope
I explained it well enough so the main
channel will receive dev vlogs and
occasionally in-depth videos on
particular concepts well the journal
archive channel will receive all of the
live streams that do happen on Twitch in
fact everything not just Pocky just
every archive kind of I'll just dump
video download there basically don't
care what it was just dump it and I'm
not even gonna render it for my computer
I don't have time to do that I'll just
explore it from twitch and that's it
done that's why I want to keep it on a
separate channel because it will be a
bit dirty okay so what's next for actual
Sparky well this vlogs actually going
pretty long run out but I'll quickly
mention a few things that I'm going to
do the first thing is we're going to
bring a few new platforms in first of
all Mac and Linux have to happen I don't
actually have a computer running Linux
so I'm hoping that someone from the
community can some what may be basically
ported to Linux or tested on Linux at
least it should reasonably work on Linux
I'm not I'm trying not to use the
windows library and you will have to
play around with some of the libraries
and headers
but it should basically work out the
blocks will mix Mac I've got a Mac so
I'll definitely test it on that make
sure it's running on Mac OS and that
should be I'm actually pretty easy but
the next big platform will work on my
sport is Android
okay I've actually got it running on
Android where's my phone all the way
over there I'm gonna get it I've already
got a running on Android so I'm going to
just implement that it see this is what
I mean like I did that at work for
example and I would have loved to push
that code to the repository but I have
to go home and stream myself doing it
again that's just so ridiculous this
engines not gonna get anywhere it's
pretty difficult to make an engine it
doesn't just take five minutes so anyway
I've got running on Android I'm going to
actually put that into the engine
properly because it's actually unlike
some weird branch and I've called the
engine something else in fact it's just
because I wanted to keep it separate
anyway um so Android will be next
iOS the reason I'm kind of shying away
from iOS a little bit because of two
reasons first of all I don't have I've
used an Android as my primary device and
I have since the iPhone 4s and also iOS
is a little bit harder to develop for it
generally has less problems than Android
but I mean you need to develop a license
you need to set up provisioning you need
a Mac with Xcode it's Sparky will
eventually support iOS but that's very
long down the path Android it's gonna
come very soon Android in fact is very
easy to setup in fact we'll beat and we
won't be using like Android studio or
some rubbish wolf not dissing that it's
probably fine for like applications but
not for games we'll be using visual
studio with Android and we'll set
everything up I got this guys don't
worry we're going to essentially perfect
2d first so all of the 2d stuff for
Sparky will be perfected first now there
are some things I want to add two to D
we need sprite sheets not just the
ability to load sprite sheets but the
ability to generate sprites sprite
sheets so say for example you load a
hundred tiles they're 32 by 32 right
their textures you load in
Texters 32 by 32 that will require four
flushes right now for the engine which
of course isn't very efficient well it
could be more efficient as one saying
it's actually that's fine for toggles
but anyway the point is you voted a
bunch of tiny sprites they're all
individual intimate images so you
haven't bothered to put them in
especially the engine should basically
create a sprite sheet and just make one
or two touches or whatever because then
of course that reduces the ability like
Thea that reduces the binding of a
hundred textures to like three or four
or even one so it definitely needs to be
able to do that blending so currently
sprites have no blending control you
have to control that in the shaders and
whatnot we also need to basically make
like a shade a factory and default
shaders and all that stuff but anyway
that aside we need sprites should have a
blending thing and finally the world of
C serialization so serialization is
something that we haven't actually
touched yet but basically we need to be
able to serialize data in terms of
writing it to disk we're not gonna do
networking stuff or anything for a while
I don't think I don't have any of that
planned yet actually I'm gonna even
thought of that
but um we need serialization to be able
to save and load files and we'll
probably be making our own format for
that as well because if we were using
something like C sharp I'd probably use
C sharp so XML serialization because
that is really good but we're going to
make our own format and we're gonna
probably see all those stuff and
probably compress the dotter and all
that stuff so we need to do that as well
those are the three big features I think
remain I don't know I've I kind of I've
discussed it a little bit just with my
friends and I think that's probably
about it for a 2d renderer that's really
all we need I will tell you render or
plus I shouldn't you know game engine
wise up off from that third rendering
aside you know we've got some other
stuff like physics so we need box to
date and whatnot and that's probably
about I don't know off the top of my
hand that's probably about it
yeah physics and serialization
all the turn on renderer features that
we probably made I don't know I can't
think of anything else right now
but anyway that's the idea so that's
what's coming up next we're going to
move on to 3d once that's done I expect
that to be done by the later part of the
rig we'll move on to 3d maybe in the
next few months
and the other thing that's going to
happen is so tools we're not going to
develop tools until we're basically done
with 3d the reason is well tools take a
really long time to make and by tools I
mean something like a level editor like
unity or something that will take a
while okay it won't be particularly hard
but it will take a while which is a
problem so I don't really want to do
that I'd rather get the engine because
you don't need tools to make the game it
just makes your life easier right so I
want to ride rather get the game the
engine to the point where it's you know
good and then worry about tools because
tools are something that will take a
like a long time some tools will be made
though like a built tool for example so
we need to be able to generate project
files for Android and script and all
that stuff we probably need an
inscription plug like a spark amps
Krypton plugin for visual studio and all
that stuff so those kind of really like
small tools that will probably take a
couple of weeks to develop or whatever
I'll do those that's fine and of course
I'll stream them or not but um big tools
like a level editor or like a particle
editor that kind of stuff that's nothing
we need we need and when we'd like a
visual effects system or a particle
system so that will happen as well
anyway yeah so we're not going to do
stuff like tools I'm gonna save that for
later cool anyway those that's what's
gonna happen with Sparky I hope you guys
are happy with that one more thing I do
want to mention is if I have time and
this is going to be something that I
it's not very easy to make these series
but I'm going to try I'm going to try
and make a basically a beginners C++
series now I really hope that well two
reasons well two things really AI don't
get bored and be B I can explain it well
enough I hope because like teach I've if
you haven't noticed I've kind of avoided
teaching Java or C++ because I do
actually tutor it privately that's the
chair like home slash tutoring if you're
interested but um I don't actually make
videos on it because I just it's not
something that it's it's something that
requires a lot of work like a lot of
pre-production
essentially and I have to get everything
right and like getting everything right
factually is pretty easy but getting
everything writers and I want to mention
everything about something when I'm
talking about it but I also want to give
a concise it requires a lot of
pre-production I have time to do that
but I really want to do that for C++
because AI am not really happy with the
C++ resources out there but be a lot of
you guys aren't watching Sparky and I
tweeted the fact that I wanted to make a
C++ series and if you guys were
interested to go like 50 favorites
really quickly which is I think the most
I've ever had for a tweet honestly so
all of you guys really want that so I'm
going to try my best to do that
but just don't expect that anytime soon
basically towards the end of the year
maybe okay cool anyway that's all I
wanted to say so leave some comments
below I really want to read what you
guys are saying about this I'm going to
as always if you want to know when I'm
streaming next live dr. chanoor comm has
a countdown timer to the minute I go
live
assuming I'm not late inland usually am
but that aside leave your comments below
I'm going to read all of them and
hopefully we can hopefully we can we can
make Sparky really really good all right
guys thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time goodbye whoa